có thể đánh bệnh của mình,
trong số trở gài lix sử của tân tộc.
Cú nước Việt Nam đã khẳng định vài cho quan trọng trên hầu hết
khách lĩnh vật của đời sống xa hội.
Chên các viện đàn của tế, các nước đã biểu Việt Nam luôn tự tin,
chủ đầu.
Đó góc nhiều sáng tiến, khách lĩnh các kết mạnh mẽ của Việt Nam
đối với các ngủ tiêu pháp xin bên vận của liên của quốc về biện nạn lấy.
Chú tế của hội đánh giá khá vài cho nông quốc của tổ chức hội.
Trong tập hợp đàn kết và đồng hành của phụ nữ cả nước,
đất thị hiện gió nếp.
Các các hội đã thực hiện những túc và xa sếp
tổ chức hội mấy thêm hồn hình chính quyền mặt cấp.
Thế ứng nhành với môi hình hả động mới,
và đảo hội hệ thông hội được thung xuất.
Chú tế của hội chân thành bệnh nhận mạnh.
Đất nước tà đăng đất vào giả đạn phát xin mới,
với yếu cầu rất cao về mời mặt.
Đặt giá yếu cầu của nữ không chỉ là lực lượng tham gia
và phải thức sửa trở thành một trong những chủ thể quan trọng,
kiến tạo thức lai và phát xin đất.
Hội liên ở phụ nước Việt Nam cần phải đối mở mạnh mẽ hơn
hả động dầu qua thích thường hơn,
đưa người kết đả hội mấy bốn của đàn,
hãy kết đả hội mặt chân tổ cốc lần thương miệm một.
Và đại hội phụ nước các cấp nhành trọng và cuộc sống.
Chú tế của hội yếu cầu,
hội quan tâm hỗ trợ phụ nước xây dựng ra điện Việt Nam,
tiến bộ, văn mình, ấm nó, hạnh thúc.
Nhất là trong bối cảnh sáng hội biến đổi nhành,
tắt động dầu mặt của không ra mạng,
bám được đời sống hành này,
khết quả hả động của hội.
Và đừng đó bằng sự hành lòng của phụ nước
và chất lộ sống của bội phụ nước và chả em.
Vết cảnh đó,
hội cần chú đồng hơn trong nằm mắt thực tiến,
tham gia sế dựng,
bọn giám sát và phản biển các chính xách liên quan đến phụ nước
ra điện vào biển đàn giới.
Đặc biệt, là phải gần buối,
lắng ngay và thấu hiệu phụ nước,
mà đầm không có phụ nước nào bị sâm hạnh,
bảo lực, bảo dưới,
mà tụ trước hội không biết để mở về
bối cơ sở hội,
cán bộ hội,
phải thích sự chờ thành biển tựa bị nghiên cho phụ nước khi cân,
hội sây dựng hế hệ phụ nước Việt Nam có bản lĩnh sáng tạo và hội nhập.
Phát triển các nền tàng số cộ đồng không tập,
nhất là phòng trào bình rất hồng cửa số,
mặc lưới hối chở người nghiệp,
khởi nghiệp, lồ mối sáng tạo,
tạo được khiển để phụ nước trẻ tham gia nhiều hơn và khoản lý xa hội,
phản động cộ đồng,
nhất là các lĩnh vừa qua hồng phụ nghệ,
chú tiết hội trên thánh bánh tít tưởng,
hối chở thống tốt đẹp,
tình thần nhiều lước,
đất khi xin, lòng nhân ai,
sự sáng tạo và hãy chỉ vườn lên mạnh mẽ,
phụ nước Việt Nam sẽ tiếp tục có nhiều đón có có lớn hơn nữa,
trong sự phát triển nhanh và biển vượng của đánh nước trong kiểm mấy,
sứng đáng hối tắm sự bàn,
mặc bao gồm kĩnh nhiều đá tặng phụ nước Việt Nam,
anh hùng bất quất, chúng hậu,
đáng đáng.
Đây hội đã bầu bàn cho phản chung hình hội,
lĩnh hệ phụ nước Việt Nam khoảng miệ bốn,
gồm một chăm mề mồn đồng chi,
bà lấy tị thủy,
tại đất kỳ chủ tịch của liên hệ phụ nước Việt Nam khoảng miệ bốn,
giận ký hành hùng chăm mề sấu,
hành hùng chăm mề mốt.